monsieur macklem bonsoir bonsoir et
merci
mais vite et merci à vous d'être là on
vous sent optimiste monsieur macklem
pour la croissance de l'économie pour
l'emploi
est-ce qu'on peut tourner la page sur la
crise ou est-ce que vous êtes encore
inquiets nous sommes plus confiants les
vaccinations va très bien au canada
les restrictions de confinement sont
assouplies à et dont l'économie est en
train de mourir
on a vu en juin une forte hausse de
l'emploi
on anticipe que cela va continuer il y a
toujours des inquiétudes
le virus est encore là il ya les
variants qui sont pas très serré au
canada mais aussi certains autres pays y
sont plus sérieux dont il y a toujours
des incertitudes mais nous sommes plus
confiants de la crise qu'est ce qui va
soutenir l'économie au cours des
prochains mois quel va être le moteur de
la croissance
le premier moteur c'est vraiment le
consommateur on anticipe que les
consommateurs pour revenir à nos
activités de dépenses plus normal allez
au restaurant on est en vacances et dont
cela va stimuler sont tous les devants
pour les services qui était le plus
affecté par cette pandémie a mais depuis
on voit une forte reprise aux états unis
ça va créer plus de demandes pour nos
exportations et avec plus de demande
intérieure des consommateurs et plus de
demandes l'extérieur nos exploitations
les entreprises devaient augmenter leurs
investissements dont avec ses profs
acteurs on pense qu'ils vont voir une
ligne assez forte reprise pendant des
prochaines de toi trimestre une des
inquiétudes par contre monsieur macklem
pour les économistes pour les canadiens
c'est l'inflation on est
déjà à 3,6 pour cent c'est un sommet en
disant mais vous vous dites que c'est
temporaire qu'est ce qui vous fait dire
ça il y a plusieurs raisons pourquoi on
pense que c'est un problème
premièrement qu'est-ce qu'on les prix
des beaucoup de choses maintenant ils
sont élevés mais ils sont élevés
vis-à-vis qu'est-ce que c'était un an
passé un an passé les prix de plusieurs
biens par exemple le pétrole était très
bas dont les prix vraiment ont normalisé
vert qu'est ce qu'ils étaient avant le
pandémie ça c'est un effet kaboré de
plus on voit quelques culotte dans ce
règlement
qu'est ce qui arrive c'est le demande
pour quelques services quelques biens
revient plus vite que l'offre a par
exemple estimé qu'une docteur il y a des
problèmes dans la chaîne de plus j'aime
d'approvisionnement globale et dont il
ya une pénurie de ces semi conducteurs
dans la pulsion d'auto et plus bas et
les prix sont plus haut
ce sont des problèmes son problème de
rouvrir une économie mais avec le
rupture on pense que les entreprises
vont trouver des manières de résulte ces
problèmes d'offre et danser c'est
l'effet sur les prix sur l'inflation
sera temporaire je veux souligner que si
c'est pas temporaire on sait quoi faire
on cible d'inflation on a les outils à
et on est capable et on veut contrôler
l'inflation est justement parce que dans
votre rapport sur la politique monétaire
vous dites que le taux d'inflation va
dépasser 3%
ça pourrait être davantage jusqu'où vous
êtes prêt à tolérer l'inflation avant de
hausser par exemple taux directeurs
qu'est ce qui est vraiment c'est
important c'est notre prévisions pour
l'inflation
maintenant on pense pour les raisons que
je vous ai donné et le fait
qu' il y a encore beaucoup d'offres
exemple excédentaire dans la chronique
fille
le taux de chômage est et où il ya
beaucoup de canadiens qui n'ont pas un
job cela mais des pressions à la baisse
sur l'inflation
donc c'est pourquoi fondamentalement
nous sommes confiants que l'inflation va
baisser à 6 aussi notre prévisions pour
l'inflation change considérablement et
on pense que l'inflation dans à rester
en haut de notre fourchette cible de
bras droit cela c'est là un signe que on
devrait avoir une politique monétaire
plus à moins de départs volontaires et
ne pas lutter commentaires du sert et on
va parler d'immobilier monsieur macklem
dans les derniers mois vous vous êtes
inquiétés de la surchauffe sur le marché
selon bloomberg le canada est un des
pays du monde les plus à risque d'une
surchauffe d'une exubérance à quel point
c'est une menace pour l'économie comme
vous soulignez oui ici au canada c'est
une vulnérabilité ici au canada
ah on a vu une forte demande pour les
maisons
presque partout dans le monde c'est la
française assez unique du crise tout le
monde est à la maison à toute la journée
et dont plusieurs plusieurs ménages le
plus d espace et c'est au canada c'est
c'est aux états unis c'était en europe
dont canada sais c'est pas une et quand
cet égard qu'est ce que c'est deux
raisons pourquoi c'est le mot liberté
est à caracas et même avant la crise on
avait une endettement des ménages a
élevé et dont nous avons dit plusieurs
fois que les ménages devraient être
prudent quand il prend des hypothèques à
des mesures ont été pris par le bc il ya
fait
le canada pour redire cette crise et
qu'est ce que nous avons dans notre
prévision c'est on pense que l'activité
dans les marchés du logement va modérer
de manière assez graduel s'est encore
élevé
et oui bjarne riis a peut être peur à la
hausse ou à la baisse mais le prévisions
quand il sait pas une modification
graduelle et pas de vous ne prévoyez pas
de choc par exemple pour les ménages
pour l'endettement des défauts de
paiement quand les taux vont commencer à
remonter dans un an
c'est un volubilité maintenant on va les
et nombre par exemple des ménages qui
sont en faillite c'est assez bas à et
quand on dans le futur quand finalement
commencent à augmenter les taux
d'intérêt ont voté en compte le fait que
la politique monétaire peut avoir plus
d'effet quand les ménages ont plus de
dettes dont votre sensibilité sera bien
accueilli j'en suis certaine
alors parlons d'emploi et nous reste
quelques minutes monsieur macklem vous
dit de vous inquiéter de cicatrices à
long terme pour le marché de l'emploi à
la suite de cette pandémie qu'est ce que
vous voulez dire si vous regardez le
taux de chômage à long terme c'est très
élevés et le risque c'est que quand les
personnes ne travaillent pas pour
longtemps à izon d'une perte des
expériences ils ont une perte de
entraînements il ce pas diminué de
revenus ou à une période de temps assez
lent surtout pour les jeunes c'est très
important parce que votre moteur
entraînement dans mon premier job c'est
très important pour votre toutefois
carrière donc nous avons nous avons des
inquiétudes au sujet du scar 1 mais je
veux souligner aussi que de fait que
nous sommes plus confiants dans la
reprise du fait qu'on voit on pense que
surtout les acteurs qui sont le plus
affectés durant cette crise pour avoir
d'une forte des fortes hausses de
l'emploi à on nous sommes un peu plus un
peu plus - inquiétude donc été par le
risque de ce carré mais oui ils vont au
bord du k reen on espère que c'est un
peu moins qu'anticipé
de manière générale monsieur macklem
vous croyez que cette crise
on va tourner la page et donc vous
prévoyez une accélération de la
croissance là pour les prochains mois
oui c'est ça je veux souligner que oui
tous les lots page oui mais il ya des
risques qui désirent les inquiétudes le
virus est encore là et c'est très
important que tout le monde au canada
est en bonne santé et on peut avoir une
économie en bonne santé c'est macklem
jour merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous
merci à vous